>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," KANYE WEST, NOW KNOWN
AS YE IS ONE OF THE BEST-SELLING
MUSICAL ARTISTS IN THE WORLD,
CELEBRATED AND VERY HIGHLY PAID
FASHION DESIGNER.
FOR DECADES HE WAS WELL-KNOWN TO
TV AUDIENCES AS A IN LAW OF THE
KARDASHIAN FAME.
IT WAS HIS LATEST INCARNATION AS
A CHRISTIAN EVANGELIST THAT
BROUGHT US TO HIS OFFICE FOR THE
INTERVIEW YOU'RE ABOUT TO SEE.
DAYS AGO DURING FASHION WEEK
WEST ACCOMPANIED BY HIS FRIEND
CANDACE OWENS UNVEILED A T-SHIRT
THAT SAID SIMPLY "WHITE LIVES
MATTER" THE RESPONSE FROM THE
FASHION INDUSTRY WAS
INSTANTANEOUS AND UNIFORM.
SHOCK, HORROR, RAGE.
THERE WAS NO EXCUSE FOR THIS
FUND OR "THE NEW YORK TIMES," HE
IS LEGITIMIZING EXTREMISM, TREAT
ROLLING STONE.
WHAT WAS MISSING FROM THE
COVERAGE WAS AN EXPLANATION FOR
WHY HE DID THIS, WHAT WAS THE
T-SHIRT ABOUT?
AND NO ONE SEEMED TO THINK TO
ASK HIM MUCH LESS LISTEN TO WHAT
HE HAD TO SAY.
THE ENEMIES OF IDEAS DISMISSED
WEST AS THEY HAVE FOUR YEARS AS
MENTALLY ILL, TOO CRAZY TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY.
LOOK AWAY, IGNORE HIM, HE'S A
MENTAL PATIENT -- NOTHING TO SEE
HERE.
IS HE CRAZY?
YOU CAN JUDGE FOR YOURSELF AS
YOU WATCH WHAT WE ARE ABOUT TO
SHOW YOU.
HE HAS HIS OWN IDEAS, WE CAN SAY
THAT -- CREATIVE PEOPLE TEND TO
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE ARTISTS NOT
ACTUARIES PERIODS SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS GIVE THE IMPRESSION OF A
MAN CHANNELING HIS RAWEST
EMOTIONS RIGHT ON INSTAGRAM.
IT'S OFTEN USED AS AMMUNITION
AGAINST HIM IN THE BATTLE FOR
INFLUENCES OVER AMERICA'S YOUNG
PEOPLE.
BUT CRAZY?
THAT WAS NOT OUR CONCLUSION.
WE HAVE RARELY HEARD A MAN >> SO
HONESTLY AND SO